STEPHANIE WONG: Hey,
everyone and welcome
to the very first episode
of Ask Google Cloud.
The show where you get to
ask Google Cloud experts
your burning questions like,
are dogs or cats better?
I'm just guessing
that's going to be
way too controversial
so we're just
going to stick to Cloud topics.
I'm Stephanie Wong, a Google
Cloud developer advocate.
And today I'm joined by Martin
Omander, developer advocate
for Google Cloud Serverless,
and James Ward, also
developer advocate, also
focused on Serverless.
So today we're going to be
answering questions submitted
by you, our amazing and dynamic
Google Cloud YouTube audience.
We're always looking
out for your questions
about Google Cloud products, so
be sure to leave any questions
you might have in the
comments of our videos
using the hashtag
#AskGoogleCloud.
We actually read them.
Yeah, I know.
What a concept, right?
And if you also have other
questions that come up
as you're watching today, please
type them in the live chat
and we will do our best to
try and get to them all.
We'll be hosting Ask
Google Cloud segments
throughout the year, so be sure
to subscribe to the channel
to get notified every time
a new episode comes out.
With that said, let's go ahead
and get started with today's
topic, "All Things Serverless."
So our first question
comes from @Ajayanudeep.
Sorry if I butcher names.
What workloads work
well for Serverless?
I think this might be the
million question of today.
So Martin, why don't we go
ahead and start with you?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, we do a
lot of surveys with developers
and ask them what they
use Serverless for.
And one of the top use cases
that always comes in is APIs.
Either you have an API that
you build between your system
and another system.
Or you have an API that
sits between your backend
and your mobile client, or your
backend and your web client.
And Serverless is great
for that because we're
talking about API calls that's
like a quick little thing that
needs to run.
And load can vary a
lot over time as well.
And Serverless really
shines for that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Amazing
explanation, yeah.
JAMES WARD: Yeah, anything
with real dynamic load
where it's constantly
changing the traffic.
So if it's fluctuating
based on time of day
or maybe you need to
support a Super Bowl ad,
something of that scale,
the ability to scale from
zero all of a sudden
to millions of people
using a particular service.
That's where
Serverless is great.
It's just that huge
dynamic fluctuating scale.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
it sounds like--
JAMES WARD: Data processing
is another great one.
STEPHANIE WONG:
It sounds like it
can vary from small workloads
to large, so is there a size
differential or
is there something
that it's more particularly
suited towards in terms
of workload size or API calls?
MARTIN OMANDER: I think
it actually works really
well for small workloads when
you have something every now
and then that needs to run.
Then you don't have to pay
for the server 24/7, only
when it's executing.
But also good for
large workloads
like you were
saying, James, here.
The Super Bowl ad comes on
or Black Friday rolls around
and it's a big
variation in traffic
when this large
traffic-- so I think it's
actually good for both.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
OK, so we have a
lot of questions
so our second
question comes from,
@Jayesh, who asks,
"How are serverless
architectures better?"
And I feel like
this might be one
of those it depends
answers but let's go ahead
and go to you, James.
JAMES WARD: Sure, yes.
I think to talk about this
one of the useful things
to focus on is Cloud
Native architectures.
And when you build
for Cloud Native,
or it could also be called
Twelve-Factor architectures.
When you build for these things
that can dynamically scale,
can go from zero to as many
backing servers as you need,
then your architects
needs to support that.
So it needs to be able to
handle that up and down,
that fluctuation.
And there's certain
architectural things
that make this easier.
So for instance,
if you don't have
any state in your actual
application or service,
that's one thing that allows
you to easily scale up and down.
You move that state
back to a database,
back to an external
cache that sort of thing.
And so Twelve-Factor
and Cloud Native
are going to really be
the thing that enables
you to embrace Serverless.
And that's great, whether
you're on Kubernetes
or on Cloud Run or really
any serverless platform.
MARTIN OMANDER: And I think
working with a large retailer,
right now, and they're using
Serverless because they're
large retailer but small team.
They can't afford to pay--
have lots and lots of ops
people monitoring servers.
And they want to build stuff
and enable more services,
not sit around and
monitor services.
So they've gone serverless
for that reason,
to make their own
team more efficient.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, and I think
this is a good segue
into our next question
whose from,
@maaanonion, who asks,
"What's the difference between
Serverless and Cloud Native?"
I think we hear both
of these terms a lot
and I don't know if
they're interchangeable,
but it sounds like
they're related.
James, what do you think?
JAMES WARD: Yeah, they're
definitely related.
I look at Serverless more
of, as Martin was saying,
the like operational model
of Cloud Native applications.
You certainly can do Cloud
Native without Serverless,
without going full
serverless, and without having
that dynamic scaling and
the managed platform.
But if you're Cloud
Native, then it's
going to make it a lot easier
for you to also be serverless.
If you're starting
with non Cloud Native,
first focus on
being Cloud Native.
And then that will
enable you to also
be serverless for the
operational aspects to that.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, and
here's a personal question.
You were talking about
moving state outside
of the application logic.
How difficult is it, in
your opinion, for companies
who may have a
monolithic app or legacy
applications to move
to more of a Cloud
Native or Serverless model?
JAMES WARD: It can
definitely be challenging,
because we traditionally
have architected applications
to be these what we call--
or no, we want to treat
them as cattle not pets,
is the terminology
that we've heard used.
And it's kind of a mean way to
talk about cattle because we
love cows, but the idea
is that with your pets
you really love your pet
dearly and you don't ever
want that pet to go away.
And so with our
traditional architectures,
we would make sure that the
server should never go down.
You try to keep that
thing running forever.
And if it goes down
you have an outage.
Whereas in Cloud Native,
we're actually architecting
to support the ability to fail.
Because we know that at
the scale and at the--
when we move our architecture
to huge data centers
that are managing
millions of machines
that things may
break at that scale.
And so we have to
architect for that.
And so that's one of the key
things about Cloud Native
is moving that state out.
And so it can be a huge
challenge to going Cloud Native
and going serverless, just
things like the file system.
In Serverless and Cloud
Native, you typically
don't write files
to the file system
expecting them to be there if
that server instance goes down.
So that means you then have
to use an external data
store to store your files on.
And of course, you can use the
Google Cloud Storage service
if you're on Google
Cloud, or other options
as well depending on where
you are, just for files.
But then databases
are another example
where you don't want to run
your-- back in the LAMPs stack
days we would run our Apache
server and/or MySQL server
on the same actual server.
And if that thing went down or
the hard drive is corrupted,
you're in big trouble.
Now we need to take
those databases
and also move them out to
an external data store.
So you could use things
like Cloud SQL as one way
to externalize
those data storage.
But that allows you then to
have an elastic application
or service here that can then
talk back to that backend data
store.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
I think it speaks
to this idea of modularization
and ensuring that you're
separating compute and storage.
So that you can scale
both of those things
independently and run in a
very distributed environment.
OK, so we have a lot
of Serverless products
at Google Cloud or the top three
that we always speak about.
But @Loppy2345, asks here,
"Please explain the difference
between App Engine and
Cloud Run and which one
we should be using?
And this is actually one of
our more popular questions
we've gotten from
multiple people.
So, Martin, why don't you
go ahead and take this one?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, I
think actually over time,
we have seen App
Engine and Cloud Run
becoming more and more similar.
Because as we are all learning
about Cloud Native and Cloud
providers, like Google, and
developers, like you guys,
we're all adopting
these best practices
that James talked
about a minute ago.
So because App
Engine and Cloud Run
adopt all of those
best practices,
they're fairly
similar I would say.
And if I start a new
project I think about,
what does the team know?
Does the team know
either of these products?
Then pick that product.
If the team knows
both or neither,
I guess I would use
Cloud Run if I already
have a container-based developer
workflow, if I like containers.
Some companies do that
because in Engine you
don't have containers.
In Cloud Run you can have
containers if you want to.
But both are perfectly
good choices.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, and is there
a path from App Engine to Cloud
Run if somebody was interested?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
you're typically--
in App Engine for
example, you would
write a Node app or
a Python native app
and deploy to App Engine.
And you really don't
have to change anything,
or I guess a few lines at the
top of your file to move it
from App Engine to Cloud Run.
So it's fairly easy.
JAMES WARD: Yeah, one of
the biggest challenges
there is just to go into
a container-based, Docker
container-based
packaging method.
And there [? are ?] some
easy ways to do that.
So there's something called
Buildpacks and we have
the Google Cloud Buildpacks.
And you can take an
existing source code base
and give it to
Buildpacks and it'll
create a container for you.
If you need more
flexibility or you
want to have more
control over the process,
then you can use a
Docker file as the way
to define how your
container gets created.
But both of those are now
supported by Cloud Run,
so when you do a
source-based deployment
with Cloud Run similar to
how you do it on App Engine,
we will use a Docker file if it
exists to create the container
or we'll use Buildpacks
to fall back to.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Awesome, So it sounds
like there are tools
that people can
use if they're interested
in transitioning over.
One of the other questions that
we get often about Cloud Run
is, "Does somebody need to
truly understand containers
to use Cloud Run whatsoever?
Martin and James, I'm sure you
both have opinions on this.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, I mean.
So it used to be that you
had to understand containers
and you had to
create a Docker file.
But now you can do
gcloud run deploy source.
And you just deploy like your
Native Node app, or Python app,
or Java app and it's
deployed from source.
And under the covers it's all
containers on Google [? site ?]
but you may or may
not see the container.
So depending on if
you like containers
you ca have your own Docker
file and do that stuff.
If you don't like containers
just deployed from source.
But it's all
containers over here.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, I
feel like that's worth
restating just how
easy the experience can
be to build from
source for somebody
who may not want to understand
containers at that level.
I think it just speaks
to how we're continuously
creating higher
levels of abstraction
for those who do want
to focus specifically
on just the application logic.
JAMES WARD: The nice thing is
that containers are still there
and they're
underneath the covers.
So you get that
portability that containers
gives you, where you can
take that same container that
may have been transparently
created for you
and run it on Kubernetes,
run it via Docker
on your local machine.
Wherever Docker
container runs you
can run that container, which is
nice to have that portability.
So it's still containers
underneath the covers
but you don't necessarily
need to think about containers
and how they get created.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, you
can reap the same benefits.
That's awesome.
So with the next question @JimH.
This is a little
particular, but he
wants to share his Python apps
APIs with his friends using
Google Cloud Run,
but he is completely
unfamiliar with
containers or how
he might package his
Python or Windows API
so he can take advantage
of Google Cloud Run.
Where does he start?
Similar to, I think, what
we just talked about, James.
You said Buildpacks
is one option.
Anything else here to add?
JAMES WARD: Yeah I think
Buildpacks are really
the transparent way to go
from that Python source code
to a container.
Buildpacks are a Cloud Native
foundation-- under the Cloud
Native Computing
Foundation, they're
called Cloud Native Buildpacks.
So this is an open
standard and Google Cloud
has built our Buildpacks.
We have samples on our GitHub.
I think it's just called
Buildpacks samples
and of course there's
a Python sample there.
So check that one out.
And you'll see that
with Python there
is one little trick that
you need to know about,
which is you need to tell the
Buildpacks how to actually
start your application.
And so there's something
called a proc file,
is one way to do that.
And so that's one thing
that Python doesn't give us
for Buildpacks is the ability to
know what application to start
in your Python code.
Whereas in Node,
this is something
that you do through an NPM start
command and other frameworks
have different ways
for the Buildpacks
to know what command to start.
But with Python we don't know
how to start your application.
So that's the one
little thing that you're
going to have to add
in potentially from--
versus what you have now.
But yeah, check out the
Buildpacks samples for Python.
That should be pretty
helpful to get you going.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Perfect, awesome.
OK so next question
is from @lceus.
"Could you explain how to
set up Cloud Run on Anthos?"
James, do you want to start?
JAMES WARD: Sure.
Yeah so what's called
Cloud Run for Anthos
is a way to have the Cloud Run
experience on Anthos, which
is a way to be multi-cloud, be
on-prem with GKE or Kubernetes
Engine.
And so with Cloud
Run for Anthos,
you get all the great
things about Cloud Run
but you get them on top of GKE.
And so you can use this
either in our GKE service.
You could use it on
other Cloud providers,
you could use it on-prem.
And to get started you
first need to have Anthos.
And so if you're in the
Google Cloud console,
if you actually
go into Cloud Run
and you go try to deploy an
application, which is-- just
say-- like create service,
then you click on Anthos
as the deployment target.
If you don't already have
an Anthos cluster set up,
then it will actually
help you walk through
and create that Anthos cluster.
There are other ways to
create an Anthos cluster
on Google Cloud as well.
And once you get
an Anthos cluster,
you can then deploy to it
through the Cloud Run UI
or through the typical
ways that you deploy
to Cloud Run, which is like--
command line is one option.
You do gcloud run deploy
to deploy your application.
You can do that to deploy to
Cloud Run for Anthos as well.
But start with the console,
console.cloud.google.com.
and just go to Cloud Run and
pick Anthos as the target
and should be pretty
straightforward to deploy
from there.
STEPHANIE WONG: Cool.
Sounds like there's a couple
options there to get started
with Cloud Run for Anthos.
Our next question is
from @DheerajP, who asks,
"Do the environment variables
in the Cloud Run dashboard
allow KMS encrypted values to
be specified instead of publicly
exposing database credentials?"
Martin, what about you?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, so yes.
So first off, great question.
And the background here is--
I see that the word
public is used here.
If you have
environment-- well, so it
used to be for
years and years it
has just being considered
best practice to have things
like database passwords,
file paths, and things
like that as
environment variables.
So they are not
hard-coded in your code.
That is a great practice.
Now if you [INAUDIBLE]---- so
people have started saying,
well, actually if I have it
in environment variables then
if part of my application--
maybe I have a malicious
library somewhere in my
application that I downloaded
open source something.
It could read
environmental variables.
So I want to be even
more secure than that.
And that is, I think, is where
this question comes from.
So if you use environment
variables in Cloud Run,
they're not public.
It's only you can see them.
But you could
potentially have a piece
of malicious code
inside your application
that can read
environmental variables.
And the way to get
around that-- of course
this is, of course,
a common problem.
So to get around that you use
Secret Manager, which is part
of your Google Cloud account.
You just turn it on and
that is a very secure way
of storing these secrets
like database passwords
and so on, if you
want to do something
that's even more secure
than having just environment
variables.
And you can set
things up so they're
audited and all that good
stuff in Secret Manager.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right,
and just for those
who haven't heard
of Secret Manager,
it's a secure and
convenient storage system
for API keys,
passwords, certificates,
other sensitive data.
And it gives you this central
place and source of truth
to manage all of these
things and audit secrets
across Google Cloud.
So definitely a
great tool to use.
OK, so next question comes
from @Jorgel who asks,
"Do you have any tips on how
to accurately estimate costs
for using Cloud Run
in this way? " James,
I'm going to you for this one.
JAMES WARD: Yeah, so cost
estimation was something
that's elastic, can be hard.
This is like your power
bill, your energy bill
that you get from
the power company.
How much is the bill
going to be next month?
I don't know.
It depends on how much you use.
And so usually the way
that we do estimation,
just like you probably do
estimation of what your energy
bill is going to
be, is you base that
on what you did in the past.
And so based on the
past bill, that's
how you can determine likely--
or the ballpark of
your future bill.
So usually the way that
we do cost estimation
when you're in a environment
that is scalable like Cloud
Run, is you do a test
that tries to simulate
what your actual
traffic is going to be.
And then you take
that test and you then
see, all right, how much money
did we spend with that test.
And then you can
extrapolate from there
how much money it's going to
be when you're actually live.
There is a cost calculator that
you can use on the Google Cloud
website too.
But this is not exactly going
to give you a real world
picture, because
you're going to have
to estimate how many
concurrent connections are
going to be coming in.
Which could be really
hard to actually estimate
in your real world usage
of your backend service
or your application.
So really, if you want to
get the most accurate number,
you need to actually
run a simulation.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, it sounds
like a chicken and egg problem.
You want to find out, but you
also need to test it out first.
But do you find that there's a
certain size in this simulation
that you need to run
through to experiment
and be able to extrapolate?
For example, scale
up to thousands
of concurrent connections or
is there a certain minimum
that you think that
people need to run through
for the simulation?
JAMES WARD: One
of the hard things
is that there's a lot
of knobs that you can
turn to change the behavior.
So with Cloud Run
the default number
of concurrent connections
to a given instance is 80.
You can turn that
down to as few as one
or up to as many as 250
concurrent connections.
And this can dramatically
impact your bill,
but it can also dramatically
impact your performance.
So if you turn it all the way
up to 250, then that's great.
That means you're going to
get 250 concurrent connections
to a single instance
and you only
get billed the CPU and
memory time for one instance
across those 250
concurrent connections.
But if your workloads are
very IO and CPU intensive,
then you may actually be causing
a huge performance degradation
by doing this.
Which then may send more
request to other instances,
because they can't handle those
requests potentially as fast.
And so it's really with
simulation testing--
you want to try to
actually make the load look
as similar to the real world
load that you're going to have.
And then turn some
of those knobs
and see, if I turn the number
of concurrent connections up
or I turn the number of CPUs
up or whatever it may be,
then it's going to
change some things.
And so you're going to
have to do some testing
to figure out what the
optimal configuration is.
It's actually one of the really
nice things about Cloud Run
that you can have
concurrent connections.
Some of the other
serverless platforms
actually don't allow you to
have concurrent connections,
multiple concurrent connections,
and so then you're actually
paying like per request.
You're not getting
the advantage of being
able to handle many connections
on a single instance
and only get billed
for that one instance.
MARTIN OMANDER: And also--
STEPHANIE WONG: Right, right.
MARTIN OMANDER: --and
also in my experience,
the real world applications
I've worked on, it's
seldom Cloud Run that
is the big dollar bill.
It is usually
bandwidth or databases.
And that stuff you're going to
have whether you do serverless
or not.
And so, yeah, in my experience
most of the money lands there.
You should perhaps
look at-- make
sure you include bandwidth
and databases in when
you make estimates.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, important to be
able to isolate the issue
during this testing phase.
So our next question
is from @VildanC
who asks, "What if I want to
access my private Google Cloud
storage from Cloud Run?
Martin, won't you take this one?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, so I'm
not sure what Vildan means here
but it could be either I want
to access a Google Cloud storage
bucket in GCP that's
private to me.
Or it could be that maybe
Vildan means the Google Drive
private storage.
So if it's a Google
Cloud storage
bucket that is private to--
only Vildan can see it.
What Vildan needs
to do is to find
the name of that Compute Engine
account that Cloud Run, runs as
and then you can find
that in the Cloud console.
That looks like an email
address and then give
access for that account to
this Cloud Storage bucket.
And then you would read,
using the Cloud storage API,
it's a library you can download.
And actually--
STEPHANIE WONG: Right,
and you're referring.
Sorry, go ahead.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah and
actually it's the same thing.
If it's Google Drive
we're talking about,
I've written many
applications that
access my private to drive.
Then again, I find that
Compute Engine account.
It looks like an email address.
I share a folder
in my Google Drive
or an individual spreadsheet.
I click share, paste that in
there, and give it read access.
And now my Cloud
Run can read that.
And just like with
Cloud Storage,
there is a client library
you download to access Drive.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Oh, that's awesome.
I didn't know that you
could use the same service
account for these external
storage locations too.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, we
just released a video.
I think, is it this
week or next week,
where we actually have a
REST API running on Cloud Run
and the backend is a
Google spreadsheet.
So you don't have to muck
around with databases.
It's far easier to have a
spreadsheet as a database
and Cloud Run reads
from the spreadsheet.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Yeah, that's awesome.
JAMES WARD: The first time
that I added a service account
to a Google Drive Doc and all
of a sudden it magically shared,
I was just blown away.
I was like, whoa, all these
identities are connected.
And it was pretty awesome.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, see.
Even we still get blown away
even if you work with it a lot
every day.
And for those of you that
are listening or watching,
a service account
is this special kind
of account used
by an application
or a virtual machine, as Martin
was explaining, not a person.
So applications use
service accounts
to make authorized API calls.
Authorized as either the
service account itself,
or as Google Workspace,
or Cloud Identity users
through this
domain-wide delegation.
All right.
So we have another question
here by @DinakaranS
who says, "I would like to see
how role based authorization
can be done."
James, why don't we go to you?
JAMES WARD: Yeah, sure.
So this is back to
the service account.
So when you have
a service account
there's actually two different
sides of the service account
in Cloud Run.
There's the service account
that the service runs as,
and then you can also
assign service accounts
that can talk to a service.
So that's one way that you can
control who actually has access
to call your Cloud Run service.
So if you want to make it so
that only particular service
accounts can make a call
to a Cloud Run service,
you can do that.
You can also give certain
people a role called,
I think it's called
Cloud Run invoker role.
Which you can say,
all right, Martin.
You have the Cloud Run
invoker role for this service
and that allows you to
then call that service.
So there's a few different ways
within IAM and Google Cloud
to configure it.
But certainly Cloud Run
services can be locked down
to specific service accounts,
specific users, specific roles
that can make actual HTTP calls.
And if they don't
have that, then it's
actually Google Cloud
that blocks that.
Your application doesn't
need to have that logic
to do that block, do
that role based off--
Google Cloud just
does that for you.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
also and service
accounts that's
great for if you have
like machines, calling machines,
and machines calling services.
If Dinakaran is
talking about end users
coming in through a web
browser and hitting services,
then you probably want
to look at Firebase off.
That is one way of
dealing with it.
You put Firebase,
open your servers,
and now people can sign in
with their Google accounts,
or Facebook account,
Apple account.
There's a bunch of checkboxes.
You can turn them on and off.
And you should also--
I want to put a bug
in your ear Dinakaran
about identity aware proxy.
That is also a product that can
sit in front of your App Engine
apps.
And you can for example
say, everybody at my company
can do this, and only the
people in the finance department
can do this, access
these few services.
So there are many things
to choose from, but have
a look at Firebase off
identity aware proxy.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
I'm very glad you brought
that up because this
is a perfect segue
into our next question
who is from @NeilK
and he asks, "Can we expect IAP
to support Cloud Run anytime
soon?"
MARTIN OMANDER: We get
this question a lot.
So yes.
Definitely.
This is-- we're
working hard on it.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Always working hard.
Yes and as Martin
explained, IAP lets
you use identity and
context to guard access
to your applications and VMs.
So you get this central
authorization layer
for any applications that are
accessed by HTTPS specifically.
Then you can use
application level,
access control models instead
of relying on network firewalls.
Awesome.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
also by the way,
if Neil is writing
an API specifically
and it doesn't want to use IAP--
well, there is also
the API Gateway
that was just made
available that
can do-- sit in front of your
Cloud Run services or functions
or whatever and do
the authentication.
So have a look and see if IAP
or API Gateway is best fit
for your app.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
Yeah and we're going
to include hopefully
the links to some of these in
the description after this.
So if you want to check out IAP
and some of the other things
we talk about with
service accounts,
please go ahead and take a look.
OK.
So our next question is
from @SenjuV who asks,
"Does Cloud Run
support WebSocket?"
James, what about you?
JAMES WARD: Sure.
Yeah, so this was
actually just announced
a couple of weeks ago, but Cloud
Run now generally available
supports WebSockets.
I think it's actually still in
beta, so maybe not [INAUDIBLE]
yet.
Like are two different
designations,
but you can do it.
You deploy a WebSocket
application today
and it should just work.
So there's a few different
ways that you can do this.
One is that you can do the
HTTP/1.1 upgrade to WebSocket
and that works fine.
You can also do something
over HTTP/2 and use
what's called h2c, which
is clear text HTTP/2.
And Cloud Run supports
that as the mechanism
to connect from essentially
the load balancer proxy
and your application as well.
So a number of
different options there.
You could also do--
server-sent events is
a popular option, which
does chunked encoded responses.
So that's one way to do it.
And then of course
with the support,
it also brings gRPC
streaming support,
bidirectional gRPC
streaming support.
So your Cloud Run
services can actually
do bidirectional
communication on Cloud Run.
And I think that
actually ends up
using HTTP/2 underneath
the covers usually.
But really great
support for a real time
push-based applications
and services.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, wow.
And because of this
bidirectional ongoing
conversation between
client and server
and some of the
use cases you just
mentioned, do you foresee that
this support for WebSocket
does actually improve
application performance
for event-driven architectures?
JAMES WARD: Yeah, it
definitely is important
if you're doing anything
event-driven or streaming.
Where this is important
and why Cloud Run is
a great fit for this,
is that typically when
you have this event
streaming services
you have a lot of
idle connections.
And so these
connections are just
sitting there waiting
for some event
to send down to the client.
And with Cloud Run,
because you can support up
to that 250 concurrent
connections per instance,
if a lot of those connections
are just idle, that's OK.
You're not going
to have to spin up,
let's say 250
instances, to support
250 concurrent connections.
You really could handle that
on a single instance and so
that's going to save you money.
So it's just a more efficient
way to utilize those resources.
So yeah, with event-driven
architectures,
the support for
streaming, and push,
and bidirectional communication
on Cloud Run is great.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think this is really
valuable for anyone
who doesn't know that
concurrent connections
on a single instance
are possible
and that you can use it to get
the most value out of this.
OK.
So our next question
is from @DuL
who asks, "hey, a question
about Cloud Run on GKE
or Cloud Run for
Anthos, versus Knative.
Is gcloud run deploy
a thin wrapper
on top of kubectl apply?
Can I use kubectl only?
Are there any features that
gcloud run deploy provides that
kubectl apply doesn't?"
I will go to James.
JAMES WARD: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So for those that
aren't aware, Knative
is a way that you can
make Kubernetes easier
and make it serverless.
And this is actually
what's underneath Cloud
Run for Anthos.
So Knative as an open source
project with a Cloud Native
Computing Foundation.
And because it's
based on Kubernetes,
the tool to interact with
it typically is kubectl.
It's the kube control, lots
of different names for it,
but it's the way to
take a ymal document
and give it to Kubernetes.
And so when you work
with Knative or Cloud Run
for Anthos, you give a document
to your Kubernetes cluster
that describes the
services that you
want to have up and running.
And so with Cloud Run,
the fully managed version,
there isn't a direct
way to [? du coup ?]
ctl apply of a document.
And that's because there isn't
a Kubernetes cluster actually
there.
There is no Kubernetes cluster
with the fully managed Cloud
Run.
There is-- one of
our co-workers, Amit,
who created a clever
way to do this.
And so it's simulating
a Kubernetes cluster
but then does the, what's
needed underneath the covers
to talk to Cloud
Run fully managed.
But there is a way to
get ymal documents out
of Cloud Run fully managed, so
that then if you are migrating
from Cloud Run fully managed,
to Cloud for Anthos, or Knative,
you can get the ymal document
definition that defines
your Cloud Run services out.
And then you can kubectl apply
those into Knative or Cloud
Run for Anthos.
So there is great
interoperability there
between them.
But because there isn't actually
a Kubernetes cluster with Cloud
Run fully managed, there isn't a
direct officially supported way
to apply that document.
STEPHANIE WONG: Nice.
OK, thank you so--
JAMES WARD: At least
through kubectl.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, Awesome.
So we have a couple
more of them I'm
trying to squeeze in here
with the time that we have.
So @RahulG asks,
"Is Cloud Trace also
available automatically
for the Cloud Run service?"
Martin.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes.
So yes, it has some
default stuff in there.
Often I hear users
want to add more stuff,
so you get some
training for free.
If you want more
tracing you just
pull in the OpenTelemetry
or Cloud trace libraries
and then you can add more
detailed instrumentation.
And just so
everybody knows, this
is a really cool
thing Cloud Trace.
In Cloud Trace you
can see, for example,
like my slowest response times.
What happens inside those?
Is it the database that's
holding up the response
or is it calling
to another service?
And you get pretty
graphs of that
and can troubleshoot and narrow
down where things go wrong.
STEPHANIE WONG: Awesome.
Yeah, definitely
leverage Cloud Trace.
OK, so the next
question, @TheDiscoMole,
which paints a very interesting
picture in my head, asks,
"Can you speed up
your cold starts
so choosing Cloud
Run over AWS Lambda
is finally a no brainer?"
Martin, I'll go to you.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, so there
are best practices in the Cloud
Run documentation for reducing
startup times and cold start
times.
But then recently,
there is a feature
that I use on every
single Cloud Run service
I deploy nowadays when--
if I'm really concerned
about cold starts.
And that is a new feature
called, min instances.
So when you deploy your Cloud
Run service you can say,
I want there always--
I don't want it to
scale down to zero,
so that would be a cold start.
I always want there to be
at least one server ready
with my servers loaded on it.
So that way, you get way fewer
cold starts, min instances.
JAMES WARD: And you could
set that to be whatever.
So it doesn't have to be one.
If you want there to be
100 instances just waiting
for requests then you
could set it to 100.
You would, of course, pay
a little bit more money,
but certainly an option to
set that to avoid cold starts.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
And there are a
couple other things
you can do in terms
of initialization
of the container on
Cloud Run, right?
So like for example,
creating a leaner service,
reducing module
loading that happens
if you're on Node.js or Python,
shortening your initialization
in general.
Anything else to add
in terms of that?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
there's a good rundown
in the Docs for Cloud
Run about those things
that call out what you
described here, Stephanie,
and a few other things.
JAMES WARD: I'll point out
in the world of Java-- that's
the world that I'm in,
Java, Kotlin, and Scala.
There's a kind of newer tool
called GraalVM native image
that allows you to take
JVM based applications
and ahead of time, compile them.
And I was able to take an
application that would take
like five seconds to start.
And with GraalVM
native image I was
able to make it start in
like 100 milliseconds.
And so if you're in
the world of JVM,
check out GraalVM native image.
It's pretty awesome
for serverless
and avoiding cold starts.
STEPHANIE WONG: Sweet.
Cool.
Check that out.
OK, so I think this is our
final question that we have time
for today, which is from
@ManpreetS, who asks,
"It would be nice
if we could automate
processes and workflows."
I think he wants
that to be addressed.
So, Martin, how about you first?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, so I
don't know exactly what Manpreet
is asking for-- what Manpreet
means by automating workflows.
There is a product that
just became available called
Workflows.
And it works great
with serverless, also
full applications.
What we've seen when we
started using Workflow
ourselves is that
a lot of the code--
or that we would write in code
like, do this, call this thing,
wait if that happens.
You can now write
declaratively in ymal
or in JSON, which is far safer.
So all those if statements
and all that stuff
is declarative in
a file, that then
deals with basically
translating a flowchart
into calling services
in a certain order
and branching and so on.
Workflows.
Check that out.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
that just came out and--
is it in beta or GA now?
I think it might be GA.
MARTIN OMANDER:
I think so, yeah.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah.
Awesome, yeah.
I mean that's for
chaining together APIs
and it would be great to be
used in conjunction with Cloud
Run and Cloud
Functions, for example.
Or anything that has an API.
Great.
James, you have anything
else to add here?
JAMES WARD: No.
Yeah.
Thanks for asking
us great questions.
And hopefully we get
to do more of these.
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah, sweet.
Thank you so much, Martin
and James, for being on.
Y'all provided the
most insight on this,
and I think this was a very,
very valuable and popular topic
for people.
OK, thank you
everyone else who's
watching for joining our
very first Ask Google Cloud
live chat.
We hope your questions
got answered.
But if not, we'll be
back with more live chats
throughout the year.
We'll be featuring your
questions from YouTube,
Instagram, and Twitter.
So send in your questions using
the hashtag #AskGoogleCloud.
And comment below if
you have a question
that we didn't get to today.
Thank you so much for
watching, and we'll
see you all next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]